I want to walk through a couple of
different people in the ecosystem the
position that they sit in it and you
tell me what uh what you think from that
perspective as to what they should do or
kind of how it impacts them sure
so the first one if you're the President
of the United States and you see Bitcoin
what do you do and do you think it's a
threat to the country to the US dollar
do you think it's something that you
should embrace kind of you know how do
you think through that framework if
you're sitting in the Oval Office sure I
I do think Bitcoin is a threat to the US
dollar but it's not the only threat to
the US dollar right so I mean the the
remin B is a threat to the US dollar
that we know we actually have remin be
denominated you know we have petrol
remin be futures contracts now right
which is very relevant and so if I were
the president you know what my
consideration would be hey you know this
is a threat and and Pierre Rashard at
the Nakamoto Institute is written about
this in the past in the future where
Bitcoin is a credible threat to
nation-states you know we'll start to
see more and more speculative attacks
and what are the most what are the most
likely kind of first couple sure I think
that the first couple you know we're
already starting to see at the fringes
right there in countries with no capital
controls
so take Turkey this week is a perfect
example and they're starting to get shut
off right so you know just this week
we've seen Turkish citizens get shut off
from PayPal soon they'll be shut off to
you know to other sort of internet
retailers and as their connection to the
outside world is starting to get shut
off and in Bitcoin by the way Bitcoin
trading is not yet illegal in Turkey but
I do anticipate you know either that
Bitcoin will be made illegal or that FX
will shut down yeah or that you know or
or that you know I forget what I was
going to say but the like I anticipate
that this will happen in in the short to
medium term future so you think that the
first attacks are not violent in nature
they're more politically savvy in terms
of trying to use either market forces
you know access to internet access to
yes communication outside yeah I I don't
think that we're gonna see sort of like
full-on nation state level disputes over
Bitcoin yet but I think that it would be
you know prudent especially given the
amount of Bitcoin like this sort of
industrial Bitcoin concentration in
Russia and China for it would be prudent
to own some Bitcoin right and there's
been there are a few people working on
this in Ghana for example who've been
you know lobbying and working with you
know the central banks of Africa to try
to get them to hold Bitcoin exposure you
know I think we're fully at the point
right now where it's more it's more
prudent to own a little bit than to not
only in any and all and you know I would
approach it the same way if I were the
president right is to do you know two
big things one is to make sure we own
some Bitcoin and second more importantly
is to be welcoming of entrepreneurs
working on truly you know decentralized
systems because I think that what you
have and and this has been described by
a number of people but what you the
universe where the u.s. is not welcoming
of crypto entrepreneurs is one where we
effectively push away you know sort of
the potential architects of this open
financial system elsewhere and that's
not a place that we want to be at all
and I think that that could come with a
lot of now and negative repercussions
and so I think the first order of
priority is to be welcoming of Bitcoin
and other kind of truly hope in networks
and technologies while also clamping
down on you know sort of in doubling
down on investor protections and
protecting retail investors from fraud
etc etc but I think that's less of a
problem with Bitcoin specifically and
more of a problem it's kind of long tail
of crypto projects but I think that both
of those things are really important so
let's keep going with example you're the
US president you say hey we should want
some Bitcoin there's you know two three
mil two or three billion dollars a day
trading do you just go by you know as
much as you possibly can over a couple
of weeks and try to build
you know 20 30 billion dollar position
or kind of what what do you do yeah I
think that you know first I would call
the guys at the NSA and make sure they
didn't create Bitcoin if this isn't some
huge NSA ruse you know these things so
you know these things happen right we'll
find out 25 years from now what the NSA
knew and didn't know but you know even
you know RSA encryption in in a form
data actually come out with it privately
the the NSA did you know four or five
years before it was in you know as it
was went through academia but you know
the sort of tongue-in-cheek that's the
first thing I would do but you know in
in terms of accumulating a position you
know that I I don't know the specifics
about sort of what disclosures would be
required or which branch of the
government would have to approve it or
what can be done by executive order etc
but the the first focus rather than
accumulating it would probably be to
shed better regulatory clarity on on the
environment because you know the
regulations that we have now are
confusing they're they're bad for
entrepreneurs you know it's confusing
because it's it's unclear
you know because bitcoin is really new
right it's it doesn't fit into sort of
existing paradigms especially it doesn't
fit into sort of you know more
traditional conceptions of money
transmitter businesses and money service
businesses and it's it's unclear you
know well you know the IRS says one
thing the SEC says another it's unclear
what the status of it is the SEC is
attempted to shed some light on
decentralization and I think that that's
also largely sort of it's very up for
interpretation actually there are some
problems there I think as well because
what they've communicated is that
there's some sort of slide for how
decentralized something is here hey you
know I don't I I think that that's very
very hard to say right it leaves a lot
of wiggle room and so I think the first
thing you know you know sort of even
more paramount to buying Bitcoin is
actually clarifying you know what the
regulatory environment is around Bitcoin
and making clear that we are supportive
of and
encourage development and use of Bitcoin
but we'll see I mean it's it's kind of
at odds with you know with the state of
currency to some extent right it makes
for all sorts of you know actually even
more complex right so around taxation
right if I'm spending Bitcoin you know
do I have to calculate capital gains
whenever I buy a cup of coffee or you
know is there a threshold under which it
won't matter these are all you know very
relevant important questions